في غضون ذلك افادت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
انه من المتوقع ان يزيد الجيش الاسرائيلي
من نطاق نشاطه العسكري في شمال قطاع غزه
خلال الاسابيع
المقبله هذا واعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي سقوط
طائره مسيره تابعه له جنوب تل ابيب جراء
خلل فني ولم تخلف الحادثه اصابات او
اضرارا وقد قام الجيش بجمع حطام الطائره
المسيره ويجري التحقيق بشان ملابسات
سقوطها
معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري وليد نستفسر منك اذا عن هذا التطور
سقوط هذه الطائره المسيره جنوب تل ابيب هل
اتضح اي شيء بهذا الخصوص وايضا جديد
المعارك الميدانيه في قطاع
غزه لكن قبل ذلك دعيني اشير الى الى اين
تؤشر كل العقليه التي تحكم في اسرائيل
بخصوص قياده المنطقه وتحديدا قطاع غزه في
هذه الحرب الضروس الداميه بالليله الماضيه
المؤتمر الذي عقده اقطاب اليمين وانصارهم
الحاكمين في اسرائيل هذه التوليفه
اليمينيه المتطرفه وجاء تحت عنوان
الانتصار ودعوا فيه او اعلنوا انه ينطلقون
منه لاعاده الاستيطان في قطاع غزه الصحافه
الاسرائيليه قالت هذه صحيفه معارف قالت
انهم يرقصون على الدماء كانوا يرقصون في
هذا المؤتمر في القدس الغربيه صحيفه اي
دعوت احرونوت اسمته بمؤتمر الترانسفير اي
الترحيل وهذه العقليه هي التي تحكم في
اسرائيل حاليا بينما قالت صحيفتها ارتس
انهم يرقصون في مؤتمر الترانسفير هذه
العقليه التي تحكم في اسرائيل هذا ما تخطط
له لليوم التالي للحرب كما يبدو بخصوص
قطاع غزه وهذا المؤتمر حضره
12 من الوزراء وبعضهم من حزب الليكود الذي
يراسه نتنياهو و1 من اعضاء الكنيست من
كافه احزاب الائتلاف الليكود والصهيونيه
الدينيه وايضا عظمه يهوديه وغيرها وهذا
مؤشر كبير على الى اين يريدون قياده هذه
المنطقه والدفع بها وتحديدا في قطاع غزه
وهكذا قرات الصحافه الاسرائيليه مؤتمرهم
على انه مؤتمر للترانسفير للترحيل وعلى
انه ايضا يرقصون غير مكترثين بالدماء التي
سفكت من الجانبين ولكن وليد معه هذه
الطائره المسيره عفوا اللافت فيما يخص هذا
المؤتمر انه ياتي في الوقت الذي هناك
مطالبات داخل اسرائيل بالحذر فيما يتعلق
بالتصريحات المسؤولين
و نشاطاتهم بعد دعوه جنوب افريقيا امام
محكمه العدل الدوليه ضد
اسرائيل هذا يشير الى انهم لا يكترثون
لقرار المحكمه العليا الدوليه و ولا حتى
لما اوعز به اليهم نتنياهو لكن ما كانوا
ليجرؤ على عقد مثل هذا المؤتمر والادلاء
بمثل هذه التصريحات والرقص على الدماء كما
قالت صحيفه معاريف ورددت ذلك باقي الصحف
لو لم يكن لديهم ضوء اخضر من نتنياهو فهم
بينهم 12ث وزيرا بعضهم من الليكود الذي
يراسه نتنياهو وبينهم 15 نائب في الكنيست
وايضا بعضهم من الليكود الذي يتزعمه
نتنياهو وهؤلاء رقصوا ورددوا نفس الهتافات
ونفس المطالب بالاستيطان وبترحيب سك
الفلسطينيين من قطاع غزه وهذا مؤشر على
هذه العقليه نحن نتحدث عن اناس هم في صلب
دائره صنع القرار في اسرائيل وليس باناس
هامشي وهذا يشير على انه حتى ربما نتنياهو
نفسه لم يعد يكت حتى لقرار المحكمه
الدوليه الذي جاء بد من الاوامر القضائيه
التي تلزم اسرائيل بان توضح وتبرهن بانها
لا تقوم بعمليه اباده جماعيه وجينو سيد في
قطاع غزه هذا التوجه واضح على انه على
جانب عال من الخطوره حتى في نظر قطاع واسع
من الاسرائيليين انفسهم لذلك جاءت هذه
الصحف بهذه العناوين وعلى صدر صفحتها
الاولى مع و لهم وهم يقهقهون ويضحكون
ويرقصون ايضا ويرددون هتافات تطالب
بالترحيل وباعا الاستيطان من جديد في قطاع
غزه تحت شعار توسيع ارض اسرائيل هذا يدل
على ان المخطط الاسرائيلي لليوم التالي
لهذه الحرب هو يدفع باتجاه تهجير قصري
لقطاع غزه والاستيطان فيه وتحويله ايضا
الى منطقه محتله م دامه مثل ما كان قد ردد
وزير الماليه سموتريتش عندما قال بان
الحكم العسكري سيعود الى قطاع غزه طيب
وليد ماذا عن جديد المعلومات لديك حول
الوضع الميداني في
غزه الوضع الميداني في غزه اولا المعلومات
الاخيره والتي نقلتها اذاعه الجيش بان هذا
الجيش سيصعد من هجماته على مناطق في شمال
قطاع غزه بعد ان كان قد خفف قواته بذيع ان
حرك حماس عادت للسيطره وتنظيم صفوفها
وادارتها المدنيه ل شمالي القطاع من خلال
نشر عناصر مدنيه لها لضبط الامور هناك اما
على صعيد الجنوب جنوبي قطاع غزه فيتوا في
تلك المنطقه تحديدا في خان يونس حصار
مستشفى ناصر والامل وكذلك العمليات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه في منطقه مخيم
خانيونس والضواحي الغربيه من مدينه
خانيونس الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بان قواته
تحقق تقدما فوق الارض وتحت الارض لكنه
بطيء وان هناك مقاومه يواجهها في هذه
المنطقه وكان قد اعلن ان قواته خلال 24
ساعه الماضيه ايه كان لديها ثمانيه جنود
وضباط قد اصيبوا بجراح هذا حسب البيان
العسكري الاسرائيلي لكن ما يزا وكما اعلنت
مصادره بان خطته تجاه منطقه رفح ومحور
فيلادلفيا
تنتظر القرار السياسي بهذا الشان اي قرار
الحكومه الاسرائيليه هذه الحكومه من
المفترض ان تجتمع اليوم في هيئتها ال مجلس
الحرب وكذلك المجلس الوزاري المصغر للشؤون
السياسيه والامنيه المعروف بالكابينه وهو
موسع يضم وزراء من كافه احزاب الائتلاف
ليس كمجلس الحرب يقتصر على خمسه فقط بهذا
الخ صوص وذلك للاستماع للاستماع لتقديرات
وتطورات المفاوضات حول عقد صفقه تبادل
جديده للاسر مع حركه حماس